[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: In this
demo, we'll show you
how to migrate a two-tier LAMP
stack application with Migrate
for Anthos.
Let's start with our VMware
vSphere setup on-premises.
There are two VMware
VMs in this application,
one for the application
server and one
for the database server.
This CRM application
is the application
that we are going
to be migrating.
Right now, the application
is running on-premises.
Now, we'll go to Google Cloud
Platform, Google Kubernetes
Engine Cluster.
The database server has
already been migrated,
and a load balancer is already
configured for the application.
Let's deploy Migrate for
Anthos into the cluster.
After that's complete,
let's add the VMware setup
as a source for migration.
Access to the remote setup
is facilitated by a Migrate
for Compute Engine deployment.
The setup is now complete.
Let's create a migration to
generate the migration plan
YAML.
And now, we can review
the migration plan YAML
in Cloud Shell.
It's important to exclude
certain types of files
and directories
from the migration.
Now that we've reviewed
the migration plan,
we can start the artifact
generation process.
For the application server,
this includes a container image,
a Docker file, and a
reference deployment YAML.
Here, in Cloud
Shell, we can also
examine the migration
status of the application.
Now, we'll return to our
VMware vSphere web client.
A snapshot is automatically
taken on the VMware side.
This is to process the
migration without disruption
to the running workload.
We can return to
Cloud Shell and see
when the migration is complete.
Now, we'll return to the
Google Container Registry
and refresh the images.
When we look inside
the application folder,
we can see the captured
container image is now
ready in the Google
Container Registry.
When we refresh the bucket
in Google container storage,
we can look inside and
see that the container
artifacts are stored in GCS.
Now, we'll go back to Cloud
Shell to download the artifacts
and review the deployment YAML.
After inspecting
the deployment YAML,
we will apply the
deployment to Kubernetes
to test the workload.
We'll go back to the Google
Kubernetes Engine cluster
to look at the application
deployment details.
When we refresh the application,
we can see that all three
of the managed pods
within this application
are now running in a cluster
in Google Kubernetes Engine.
Finally, we'll go back
to our application, which
is no longer running
on-premises but is now
running in containers in Google
Kubernetes Engine on Google
Cloud Platform.
[MUSIC PLAYING]